الاطلاله الاولى للعروس رجوى ال سيف اثناء
عقد القران من توقيع دار ايلي صعب ثوب
ابيض طويل ترافقه تنوره واسعه من الخلف مع
تاجر مرسع بالالماس يحمل عباره رجوى من
الله وفي حفل الاستقبال ارتدت الامير نجوى
فستانا ثانيا من تصميم
الموقوف والمطرز بالورود اما الامير
الحسين فارتدى بدله مستوحاه من تصميم بدله
والده الملك عبد الله الثاني التي ارتداها
في حفل زفافه عام
الملكه رانيا المعروفه باناقتها ارتدت
فستانين الاول اثناء عقد القران اسوا
الطويل بزخارف ذهبيه من جيور وخلال حفل
الاستقبال اختارت فستانا من دار اليسا
الاميره ايمان شقيقه ولي العهد الامير
الحسين اختارت فستانا للمصمم السعودي محمد
قاشي اما الشقيقه الصغرى الاميره سلمى
فاعتمدت ثوبا ازرق فيروزي من دار السلام
كارتني
اخيرا السيده عزه سديري والده العروس رجوى
ارتدت ثوبا بلون اللافندر تعلوه عباءه
يزينها التطريز بنفس اللون على الاكمام
والياقه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات